[Music]
as the Islamic state loses ground in
Iraq and Syria his followers are trying
to open a new front here in Southeast
Asia
five weeks ago militants loyal to is
seize control of this city government
forces are still fighting to take it
back over four days in Marawi we watched
air strike after air strike
[Music]
[Music]
bummers overhead diving towards their
targets
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they've been living through this here
every day for more than a month now
there's no end in sight
we're pretty close to the front line
here the fighting is intense and it is
sustained it has been going on like this
now for several hours you see the
minarets of the mosque over there which
is where they think these militants are
basing themselves and this is part of
the problem for the Philippines military
they trained to fight these rebels in
jungle conditions but this is now
close-quarters urban warfare they are
fighting here now street-to-street
attains hoster house as the call to
prayer echoes out across the city we
fill more troops heading back to reload
through the gunfire who can hew
loudspeakers broadcasting constantly
urging the rebels to surrender
Namie attorney medina team are we a
Philippine iya they show no intention of
doing so the Islamic state news agency
released this video it claims these are
its soldiers fighting in the streets of
Marawi a few hundred men holding out
against an army and an ally of the
United States
this is powerful propaganda intended to
draw more recruits to their cause Sky
News drone footage from inside the
rebel-held territory shows the mosque
believed to be their headquarters
it can't be targeted but whole streets
have been flattened beyond what was the
commercial heart of meroe now a city of
rubble and flames hundreds of civilians
are still thought to be trapped and
hiding here this commanding officer told
us some of those caught by the militants
are being used as slaves and orderlies
some as human shields and you believe
some of them are being dressed those
teachers are being dressed we still have
we have some visuals on this one that
they are the interests there with the
block let's roll
we believe I these are civilians because
we can easily see how they move we're
trying to reach a family we've heard is
still in touch with relatives in sight
but nowhere in the city is safe now okay
there's a danger from sniper fire in the
street so we have to line up and run
across the road okay let's go as we
reach the door a bullet lands less than
a meter from our team it seems we're
being targeted every day during the
sniper bullet because we don't we'll be
what is the purpose of this multi groups
crisis and that this way till now we
feel nervous promised to be here in two
things we plan to stay inside until the
sniper threat passed but then a fire
starts the only way out is back the way
we've come
[Applause]
okay stay down
here this possible
further Onan out of immediate danger we
see the reinforcements ruling in
along convoy of armored personnel
carriers heading into the city
[Music]
more soldiers packed onto trucks
graffiti marks the route the militants
took Isis slogans painted on the
shutters above the streets tolls
blackened bananas have been left to rot
where they hang most of the quarter of a
million people who lived here have fled
we pass a dead dog abandoned in the road
[Music]
they've set up checkpoints at every
entrance to the city to search for men
and ammunition trying to get in and any
fighters trying to escape these are the
Mountie brothers the leaders of this
group the attack was led by two groups
the Mau team led by brothers Omar and
Abdullah and is nil on Happel on one of
the FBI's most wanted terrorists seen
here is said to be planning the attack
with Abdullah moti both groups have
pledged their allegiance to the Islamic
state this region with its poverty
lawlessness and the legacy of decades of
conflict is fertile ground for would-be
new militants this man's nephew was
killed in merawi fighting for the moti
he says there are many more like him
what about the miss Masseria Nami misma
Syrian army is she her own pinnacle of
being a comma Baba some poor miss was a
barangay diamond and contain and Marah
mission convinced the Baba Baba in
rubato
Nanaki mobile number beta in this video
last June
is called for those who could not reach
Syria to head for the Philippines
instead a number of foreign fighters
have already been found amongst the dead
back in merawi to mark the end of
Ramadan a temporary ceasefire was
declared a brief humanitarian pause a
small group of volunteers armed with
megaphones and religious leaders headed
in towards the front line risking their
own lives to try to save others to try
to bring some of those trapped to safety
but as we waited for news shots were
fired into our street
this is meant to be a ceasefire there
are negotiators in there right now
trying to get permission to bring these
civilians out but there are bullets
coming down this street so we're all
just taking cover
three hours later the rescue teams
returned in the arms of one of the
soldiers a 14 month old baby girl her
bewildered family huddled in the back
[Music]
they've been hiding in a basement for 33
days dazed and exhausted they still had
to be interviewed by the military but at
least know they were safe the father
finally able to give his daughter fresh
water to drink and to explain what they
had been through his wife had given
birth to their second child while they
were trapped their baby did not survive
[Music]
in the back of an ambulance nearby the
body of a 72 year old man
Hassan Ali had suffered a stroke he died
before he could be reached
even as we filmed the fighting resumed
the ceasefire over one family rescued
now on their way to hospital but how
many more left behind
Katie stalard Sky News merawi City